[Music]
Brad Pitt has been spending quality time
with a new woman but it's not what you
might think
earlier this week news broke that Brad
was building a connection with MIT
professor Neri Oxman but a source tells
eg there is no romance quote they only
have a professional relationship the two
were reportedly spotted meeting for an
architecture project our source says
Brad and Neary's friendship doesn't come
as a surprise since the 54 year old
actor is in architecture enthusiasts and
Oxman is in architect the world of
design has been dominated by the rigors
of manufacturing and mass production so
who is Oxman a few things to know she
was born in Israel studied there and
fulfilled her mandatory service in its
military Oxman has a PhD and has won
several awards in her field she was
married to a famous composer but is
divorced she is renowned for the way she
combines materials with nature and she
coined the term material ecology as et
previously reported pit has been
casually dating since splitting with
Angelina Jolie but quote the women he
sees are not in the public eye
[Music]
[Applause]